uh let's who's up next today let's go to
the 7/3 2 area code who's calling today
from 7/3 to Hyde's I mean that is you
yeah who's this oh yeah this is Elias uh
actually still have a phone number from
New Jersey but I currently live in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
alright that's still allowed that's
great
I've been listening to your show for a
few months on YouTube I'm a student at
Jefferson University in management so
this was kind of related to business I
suppose but for um for for Bernie and uh
and Biden for whoever wins do you think
that the DNC as an organization would
support the candidate that is most
likely to defeat Donald Trump or do you
believe that they kind of screw up again
and end up you know letting Donald take
the win well hold on a second you're
saying no matter who wins the primary
will the DNC support no I'm not not not
the primary excuse me if would they
would they end up supporting a candidate
who would end up not winning especially
since some other colors have mentioned
that Trump supporters may also support
Bernie so I I would not I don't agree
with a lot of Bernie's apologies I'm
actually to the right of actually Bernie
and you I don't always agree with Biden
either I consider myself a centrist but
I like to hear different perspectives
but I also to kind of believe that
Bernie would be the best in order to
capture some of trumps Trump's voters
but I'm not really sure if the DNC sees
it that way
well I there's two I'm not sure I
understand your question but so part one
is is the DNC going to try to influence
the results of the 2020 primary and I
think it would be naive to say anything
other than yes I think it's just gonna
be an influence campaign yeah that's
different than the one in 2016 we
already know about the meetings that
high-level DNC democratic fundraisers
are having we know that P Budaj edge has
been part of at least a couple of those
so I think that there's going to be a de
facto establishment candidate it might
be Biden it might be Budaj edge so
number one the DNC is going to have some
influence or try to exert some influence
the second part I don't totally know
that I get which is it's possible that
the person the DNC wants to see be the
nominee may not actually have the best
shot against Trump some polls say that
for example Bernie has a better shot
against Trump than Pete Budaj edge but
maybe the DNC wants Pete Budaj edge I
don't know so yet there's no reason to
think the DNC knows who's the best
person to take on Trump and in fact 2016
is sort of like an example of that yeah
I kind of see it as kind of outcome
driven of just getting Trump not
reelected and that's kind of the primary
thing focus on and any candidate who may
have the upper hand and may capture some
Trump voters would you know be able to
make that happen so that's that's my
perspective on it yeah now what issue
for example are you to the right of
Biden on um I'm not really sure I
haven't seen all those policies I've
been more focusing on Bernie but I I do
appreciate you know the college thing
unfortunately I actually am getting a
free ride to college but I can see a lot
of a lot of other students struggling
and I really would hope that you know as
a leftist policy free college thing
passes through but hold I realize what I
mean is you you said like two minutes
ago that you're to the right of Biden so
I'm wondering I on certain issues on gun
issues for example I'm for you know some
some freedoms being restricted for
example like more in-depth background
checks but for but for some bands for
the for the automatic gun I'm not
exactly sure where I am on that but we
think that more or less Biden's position
though I suppose though I I can't say
I'm really certain about that I have to
I have to look more into it okay all
right Elias thank you very much
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you